in the first part we presented the
communication of the Commission on space
strategy for Europe this document is the
basis and background for a further
policy of the European Union in the area
of space and it's used ministers agreed
that the document is a well-balanced
basis for our future strategy in this
area we talked about what we've done in
terms of young researchers in terms of
the tools that we have for that we told
also around the table what we want to do
more these young researchers what
they're looking for is a relationship in
between Europe and then is more than
just the funds is more than the money is
the mentorship is the follow-up is the
networking and is the recognition then
we talked about international
cooperation about our vision Europe as
the beacon of fundamental science we
need to have a vision in terms of
international cooperation international
science and diplomacy so we divide these
strategy and we've talked about the
pillars of the strategy building bridges
are what we would call science for
diplomacy addressing global challenges
in Hell's in food in water what we call
science in diplomacy and enhanced global
cooperation which we call diplomacy for
sciencing